the Online safety bill has a different
rule for adults as it does for children
yeah what's the difference then I mean
this is going to basically result in the
age gating of the internet and no one
really knows yet how that's going to
work out and are we going to need IDs to
go online we're seeing that as a growing
Trend that platforms are saying they
want to see evidence of age whether
that's giving credit card or passports
driving licenses facial recognition and
I think these things are likely that
we'll see in future years because
there's been such an emphasis on young
people's experience online and shielding
them from harm which is what the bill
aims to do now I think everyone is
surely in agreement that there are
serious risks with young people being
online but I think the idea that you can
export the responsibility for protecting
children away from parents and towards
tech companies is problematic and if you
go down that road you're going to end
end up giving them license to collect
huge amounts of data